German accent pretty decently I can even  try to do the Dutch accent but somehow  the British accent has always eluded me  do you have a Magnus Carlson invitation  though that you play tomorrow in the  first no Magnus David I've got I think  my best ones are Kasparov Wesley  Vichy and Hikaru if I had to name four I  remember name four you know chess  players you know that I could do  consistently now eats would probably be  Gary you know Magnus and stuff the  Norwegian accent is I think one of the  hardest to imitate well uh I would love  to hear your vision not because he must  be excited right now cash has beaten  Magnus our guys he has beaten Magnus how  would vicious react  well okay I mean  I thought that Magnus is for struggling  a little bit and uh and I thought in his  game against uh well after H4 it was a  position became unclear and uh and after  that I was quite shocked that Magnus um  you know blundered uh